well you still have several hours before
the mega millions drawing tonight
the jackpot 475 million dollars
there are options to buy some tickets
over the state line in arizona
the last stop which is an hour from here
or there's california
in prim and that's where sally jaramillo
joins us live from prim lotto store
about 45 minutes from here
and sally let me ask you how are the
lines looking like right now
christian i was here at the beginning of
the year you may recall
back in january where the lines were
extremely long here's what it looks like
right now as we are speaking
today many people traveled from las
vegas and california here to the prim
lotto store
the store didn't open until 10 this
morning but the parking lot was full
around 8 30 a.m joseph hagen is the vp
of marketing at prim
despite long lines today it has been
nothing like earlier this year
reminder this is in california so they
must follow california's guidelines for
wearing masks
i asked several people what they would
do if they won
i meant when that money i would go ahead
and buy me a house in vegas
cut my life insurance off paying all
that money out
as for wait times they were a little
over an hour and only 30 people were
allowed inside the store at a time the
drawing is tonight at eight this store
will close at five so the line is being
stopped right now to get tickets
for tonight's drawing but you can also
be getting these tickets
in arizona reporting live sally
jaramillo 8 news now
thank you sally what